Labor Day a holiday celebrating American
laborers marking the end of summer each
year we know it as a day filled with
events parades and also a lot of sales
but do you know its roots throughout the
late 19th century and into the early
20th waver organizers fought for greater
workers rights the Pullman Strike of
1894 south thousands of US workers take
collective action in fact 30 strikers
were killed by federal troops as they
protested for higher pay amongst a lot
of other things to appease incensed
workers President Grover Cleveland made
Labor Day a federal holiday that same
year and as a result of the labor
movement US workers are now guaranteed
an eight-hour workday and the right to
organize
so with labor rights being rolled back
in the United States is there so
something to celebrate this Labor Day
for millions of workers around the world
the first of May is their day in the
late 19th century American labor unions
were fed up